dass die gerne umgibt erdbeben sind
sammeln nüsse früchte bei denen die
eigentlichen früchte kleiner auszug aus
dem fruchtfleisch sind was sie nicht aus
dem buch toten sondern wir ausgeruht in
bern sind sogar sammle steinfrüchte
tomaten sind genau genommen
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
hetero homo auf dem server ohne kinos
weil ich hier letzten episode gestorben
dafür gibt es heute wunderschöne die
vier runden auf machen kann als den
shader an machen aber ich mag ich das
nicht mehr mit shader mittlerweile sogar
cooler darf ich nebenbei
pornos klar vorne
also kann er nicht mit aufnehmen weil
dort ja geschaltet chipkarte art und das
gibt dann ja wenn ich dann jetzt mit ihm
aufnehmen würde
da wird um eine folge erst morgen kommen
und dass wir dann blöd deswegen die mir
die nächste saison abschneiden des wegen
dem ich jetzt einer leiter auf dass es
dabei aber nicht im spiel deswegen ist
die nächste folge dann die morgen kommt
ist dann bei uns einen wieder auf dem
kanal das dann zeitgleich ja ja das wird
alle vorhaben ist sachen für den
untergrund bauern deswegen wäre ich
jetzt mein haus bald wir sind bei der
bauen
du kannst einfach mal am unterboden
hauptgrund hauptquartier war dabei und
wenn du möchtest nicht okay
dadurch dass wir zusammen machen ja okay
dann machen wir das in der nächsten
episode in der nächsten episode in der
nächsten episode von minecraft iru mit
dem über grund das hat so geredet wie
hatte mein papa dann hätte schläft nein
nicht redet der davos
ich mache jetzt andere materialien
reines brauch jetzt in den anderen touch
als nabel glaube ich auf die idee was
dann noch mal nehmen ja okay ich wollte
mein haus geht was wir können aber ein
thema einfach quatsch was fällt dir
einfach mal eben auf twitter du okay
das mache ich gleich muss hier nur kurz
macht jetzt in moskau zum idioten
anrufen überwachte schnell macht jetzt
jedoch schnell schnell ja gleich schnell
so abstrus wird wollte er mich anpacken
ich hoffe ach so ihr soll idioten der
schönen kate mit seinem nachnamen
hoffenheim bitte bitte bitte nicht dass
das hat folgen rangehen und schule
folgen logische konsequenzen dachte ich
das
das artikulation deutscher wieder
raushängen lässt aber war nicht der fall
dann würde ich die die die drei
milliarden fans auf der welt würden sich
dann anrufen fanclubs aus china darf
natürlich nicht vergessen
ja natürlich sofort bei den von
natürlich stellen würden stellen so was
jetzt auf auf twitter gerade was wolltet
dirk on crafter schon immer mal fragen
jetzt live in china so viel scheiße
wieder mit muss einfach mal einen ganzen
sachen wegschmeißen alles einfach
everything allein diese ganzen show
coupe diaz ich habe wo ich mich damals
so abgefeiert wird wo ich hab ja ich
kann nicht benennen
mit lasso ja was mein twitter account
ist übrigens beste du weißt schon und
jetzt jetzt habt getötet und dann guck
mal wie viele leute sich dann entweder
schon was wolltet con crafter schon
immer mal fragen jetzt auf den tweet
antwort punkt punkt punkt ja genau und
jetzt muss man muss mal kurz warten bei
mir wenn schon 1000 leute da wird auch
in kontakt mit garten hätten da schon
logisch weil es ja auch dann an dich
gehen würde duh hält niemand leiden du
wirst immer gemocht
selbstverständlich komme ich denn jetzt
direkt in der ersten episode
freundlicherweise
verbindlichen jörg berger ich mache mir
die decke jetzt hier auch aus diesem
sprösslings sympathisiere damit so
drathen die ersten fragen reinsch 1 007
fragt warum ist er eine ananas weil
brocken ist das mal gesagt haben sie
gesagt würde würfel erinnert wie sonst
mal die erstellte seitdem miteinanders
und also für die infineon haben und die
ich habe auch gedacht wenn ich in die
partie shirt machen sollte wie ich da
nicht irgendwo drauf stehen haben so
kommt greift ab oder sondern ein cooles
symbol was man sich auch traut in der
schule anzuziehen und so deswegen
welcher wahrscheinlich einfach so eine
kuh gezeichnete anna das dann drauf
packen oder dann mal irgendwie nicht
weil sie dann noch so drauf packt ich
habe auf jeden fall schon coole ideen
und ja mittlerweile geworden
herrlich es interessiert die aber kann
mich wirklich vom 3d supply davon was ja
ja wir sind jetzt auch bei für die
supply mit unseren wunderschönen trotz
des schon dass da das sollte jetzt auch
der werbespot raus gekommen sein
zum zeitpunkt dieser folge den den
generator zweiter helfer bei laufendem
einem banküberfall so felix fragt ist
einer von euch zufällig gerade gestorben
manche much ist das ist ja eine annahme
er fragte ich j j j
was ist sechsmal 742 bestimmt richtig
durchgezogen hatte zwei minuten schon
wieder jemand wie du aussiehst den
anderen als ok dann kommt gar nicht mehr
so heftig damals als ich das echt heftig
mit siemens schreibt wie war es kurz vor
dem rauswurf zu stehen wegen dem heck
gegen die bdp mit siemens ja es war ein
bisschen doof dass ich hab das jetzt
schon pausenhalle dass er überreagiert
hat aber mittlerweile verstehen wir uns
halt wieder alles so super die sind
sogar immer noch auf server und wir
schreiben ja auch immer miteinander nur
von uns eigentlich relativ schnell klar
dass das ganze von mir einfach dass ich
damit gerechnet bin aber es war auch so
das schaffe dann
gegen um gespielt hat er auch so ein
bisschen gehetzten als staffel direkt
getötet wurde mir wasser das direkt im
livestream getötet wurde
nur shuffle wurden hat auch seine sachen
glaube ich nicht mal wieder gegeben und
so mehr auch nicht
eigentlich gleiche situation gleiche
reaktion auch deswegen weiß ich wir
haben uns lieb und teuer bahnhof ist
aber noch nichts erzählen durch sowas
nicht jetzt nicht erwähnenswert waren
jetzt auch keine nicht so viele tote von
daher war es auch relativ egal an gute
dann fragte ich
muffy von der laden warum sind konkret
dass augen so schön meine augen sind
schön was labbadia
ich mag meine augen eigentlich gar nicht
ziehen
wie steht der guten von 69 was mögt ihr
meinen augen ich gucke jetzt mal ganz
heftig in die kern jetzt jetzt jetzt
gibt es drei milliarden kommt oder aber
gar tagen als es wurde freiwillig der
reiter ich sehe ich spüre und wie meine
seele sich ausbreitet und ich fühle eine
innere wärme in mir wie ich sie noch nie
zuvor vernommen habe so jetzt jedenfalls
erst richtig schön wenn dach drauf ist
jetzt selbst riefen schreibt wie steht
er gute kontinent zu schokolade mit
zwiebelsoße und knoblauchzehen also was
wahrscheinlich jeden morgen ok schön und
jeder speise die welt immer bleiben
bevorzugt
das habe ich doch gelöst hier muss gar
nicht machen was er rät ruhig ja ja ja
ja ok moment jeder kommen gerade fragen
reinweiße ohne ende
hier fragt er der alte anfragt oder die
altern ist der schwulen und hatte einen
offenen nicht nicht offenen hoffen
ich glaube es auch offene ehe heißen mit
cross ja ich bin schwul und wir haben
eine offene beziehung also man auf
zwischenzeitlich dann fremdgehen und so
dann wahrscheinlich die machen oder bist
du schon mal fremdgegangen geht aus okay
das schön
ich bin ich bin eine ehrliche haut das
erinnert mich jetzt natürlich schon
braun gebrannt und breit gebaut ja die
stadt ist doch auch auf dem web video
preis dieses jahr videopreis nee das ist
das ohne nicht da bin ich auch bist du
auch ja dann bin ich da
das ist ja das ist alles da war ich
letztes mal auch mit lena und so und
simon das war nicht ganz witzig da
kannst du da auch mitkommen
klingt ja ich weiß nicht ich bin ja in
keinem netzwerk man ist das ist
ich glaube am 24 mai also einem samstag
ist okay da komme ich auf jeden fall mit
ist das ist ja auch direkt in den abi
die in der abi zeit also auf jeden fall
scheint also nee ich glaube ich glaube
ich vom wirklich mit weil ich dann auch
wahrscheinlich schon in einem netzwerk
welches werdet ihr dann sehen gott ich
bin mir sicher es wird dass herr
tutorial network der youtube tutorial
mit ok
denn sonst auch email seminar das so
dann wirst du einen monat berlin und
geiler nabel also nicht nur atomuhr
april wird er ein grab für seine 1000
verstorbenen chocobos machen
ja ich glaub ich nicht wirklich mal
seinen stall machen zum friedhof werde
der verstorbene hauptsache ich werde
friedhof machen
jetzt mache ich aber gerade erst mal
hier mein haus man habe jetzt keine
fakten eingesetzt ich weiß nicht wie ich
das jetzt soll ich noch was oben drauf
packen
ich glaube ich mache sowie der über
grund zum bisschen dass ich mich damit
zu identifizieren
ja ja ja das sieht auf jeden fall anders
aus hier am geilsten wäre es halt
irgendwie wenn man die scale rüstung
noch noch irgendwie umfärben könnte oder
was weiß dass man sohn gemeinsam ist
auch weil das das wäre das ja dass das
werden ja das weiß außerdem dass wir
möglichst schnell viel abklappern von
euren kommentaren
ja ich stehe weiter im programm hutewald
staat das nicht es kommt einfach so gar
nicht sagen
alles aus als name nomura dass alle
schüler über so etwas kommt so viel mit
ananas reichen hier von wegen ich will
wissen ob ein doppelleben als ananas für
papa auf jeden fall die via papier
e-mail ist ein raum wieso trägt er immer
diese komische kappe die komisch ich
habe jetzt ein anderer ich hab jetzt
neue bei der alten keplers aber so weil
ich damals heftige eishockey fan war von
den chicago blackhawks
deswegen hatte ich mir dann irgendwann
mal vor jahren den camp black ops nicht
black box
gut dachte ich mich um meine kinder
selbstständig viel zu groß habt ihr dann
auf die ecke geschmissen gesetzt es
wieder gefunden und bin mittlerweile gar
nicht mehr so begeistert aber jetzt hab
ich mal neu gekauft weil diese andere
käppi hat mir jeder nachgekommen und ich
hasse es wenn man sich eine cap kauft
und ich weiß von welchem verein das ist
diese ganzen kleinen bobfahrer alter
scheiße ich habe schon wieder vergessen
und es hat wie sonst was ich aus meinem
brüche brandes kommt jetzt erfahrung ja
gut jetzt können erst recht weiter über
kommentare quatschen
ja und wir haben ja gar net workshops
jetzt jetzt jetzt habe ich eine neue cap
und zwar von sage ich nicht weil ich
auch nicht wieder will dass die dann
jeder wieder hat er ein bisschen dorf
jeder die ganze welt kauft den cup nach
auf jeden fall caps so ich gucke was ihr
noch was hier noch brauchbar ist so viel
anderes zeug drin das nicht mehr zu
fassen hier guck mal hier fühlt er sich
manchmal wie eine andere frucht fragt
die sofi der eine andere frucht
ich fühle mich auch immer wieder ananas
von ihr könnt ihr drückt seinen
gefühlszustand im früchten aus für mich
gerade tomate alters und welche kassen
den früchten vom härte genau richtige
richtige frucht zu machen ist wirklich
eine frucht tomaten gemüse obst ich habe
keine ahnung was die unterschiede sind
ich erkläre das jetzt mal kurz ja und
zwar als es so früchte enthalten immer
sagen und bestehen aus dem fruchtknoten
der pflanze deshalb ist doch keine
frucht klammer besteht aus blättern auch
nicht hören sind eingezogen oder
kartoffeln sind knollen oder zwiebeln
oder ingwer oder oder oder äpfel sind
auch keine vorteile eines einbruch da
jeder blüten wurden das fruchtfleisch
bildet die eigentliche frucht ist das
stellt sicher dass die kern umgibt erbin
sind sammeln erste früchte bei denen die
eigentliche politische klein minister
aus dem fruchtfleisch sind was ihr nicht
aus dem boden sondern wir aussuchen gut
im plan sind sogar sammle steinfrüchte
tomaten sind genau genommen sogar bären
wie auch die banane und die gruppe
ebenfalls eine frucht letztere sogar
eine panzer wäre
huckestein steinobst genauso wie
walnüsse also keine echten nutzer haben
trotz früchte
du siehst also auch nüsse sammeln bricht
der höchstrichter steinobst etc können
früchte sein solange sie ihren ursprung
im fruchtknoten der pflanze haben das
weiß die biologisch definition von dimo
am 05 06 2011 erst einmal leugnen man
merkt man merkt auf jeden fall lasse den
referendariat mit herr bergmann
abgeschlossen hast er natürlich
dieselben biologischen kenntnisse wie du
richtig
ja ja danke für diese erkenntnis so
struppi fehler schreibt da das
bestimmten lied für dich ich war mal mit
conny auf einem server frag mal bitte ob
er sich daran erinnern dass momente das
ganz groß und rot in ihrem kalender
jetzt große großes rotes haar nix drin
genau hinterfragt wie war dein erstes
mal fortgehen also von zu hause
wahrscheinlich nein also wahrscheinlich
weg gehen denn sie war dass sowohl das
erste mal damals mit zwölf abhängig was
kind holz die frage jetzt bezogen bleibt
wieder ein erstes mal fortgehen war ich
denke ein erstes mal party machen mein
erstes mal fremdgehen oder
so entgehen ja also jetzt irgendwie in
von den eltern weg oder party marathon
party machen meint ja so wie es mir ist
beides richtig richtig komisch das erste
mal dass ich so richtig party gemacht
habe war richtig komisch weil ich davor
immer so party abgeneigt war und immer
mehr so sorglos partys wenn ich alle
leute kennen und ich konnte irgendwie
nie ich fand es immer richtig ab wenn er
dann leute waren die ich so nicht kannte
weißt du so ganz viele dass ich mal so
richtig irgendwie weiß nicht wollte ich
irgendwie nie das sieht dass da so viele
leute sind ich nicht kenne und ich habe
mir dann auch immer so gedacht du kannst
bestimmt nicht tanzen wenn er so viele
leute sind die du nicht kennst und so
richtig peinlich dabei feiern und dann
war ich so voll dass ich gedacht habe
bögerl noch mehr trinken
und wenn man bei einem guten level ist
dann sollte man aufhören er wusste der
kleine luca natürlich damals nicht
dementsprechend nach eher rückwärts
gegessen aber ja das erste mal komisch
aber jetzt mittlerweile ist ganz
natürlich werdet alle freunde sind auf
einem computer auf ihren zweiten sonntag
18 mittlerweile man kommt halt überall
rein
wenn man konstant war
und ja also nicht ja is cool water am
reck gewonnen
mein erstes mal fortgehen gut weiter
julius fragt
könntest du ihr euch vorstellen mit
einem fan befreundet zu sein
ich will dass befreundet von daher
wichtig alle deine videos schaue ich mir
andauernd an ich kann sie alle auswendig
von den formen vorm schlafengehen nach
dem schlafengehen beim neuen hafen gehen
alles immer einfach beim mit jemandem
schlafen ja auch immer ich krieg das gar
kein hoch gestiegen da einfach an oder
schreibt unfähig etwas gutes für radio
schreibt unfähiges stück scheiße ist er
kann doch nicht so schwer sein karotten
anzubauen
ich muss die chance haben ein unfähiges
stück scheiße heftig faule eier alte was
hab ich denn das ist ja normal
ich halte sich aus als ich muss gleich
mal ich glaube ich immer ganz ernsthaft
raus weil dem geburtstag
es vergeht auch nicht es bleibt einfach
werde flachzange ihr schreibt simon oder
babacan 0 sich mal verkehrt
ich habe gehört dass luca ein geheimes
mitglied des untergrundes ist ich das
passen
quatsch also kann jetzt schon lustige
dinge hat gab mich zu töten
ja und glaubte er ist es das wohl des
volkes ihr über alles unter
hier ne export du was was deine mama
passt jedoch noch eine frage eine frage
so komische fragen drinnen wie zum
beispiel
achja spatzen kind frage wie steht er zu
wissen aber nicht denn eigentlich schon
mit dieser mit dieser ehe dieser offenen
er mag ich foto untertreibt gestiefelte
städtchen ist lediglich kettchen
kettchen mit welchem youtuber würdet ihr
gerne mal was machen am liebsten
eigentlich mit kinos passagieren toll
toll dass ich mein jugendtraum erfüllt
freut mich und ich nehme ich gern was
machen mit jacks gelb am liebsten wissen
dass diesen cool pornodarsteller
erzählen ich ja sechs cap gibt es mal
auf youtube ein die haben 32 millionen
abonnenten davon an der luga noch
träumen ja träumen gar nicht freuen
die sind heftig cool wir sehen
öffentlich kugel ja das wäre mein traum
mein traum war ein schwarzer vorne ein
paar pfeile rein warf eine rein was auch
nicht mehr
als auch nicht mehr jetzt auch ein paar
felder rhein main rhein
es ist 20 und 19 und 38 sekunden am 16
12 01 14
dass diese inhalte
diese kostet denn das jetzt zu viel gut
egal mir sonst egal sein
gut ich frage sie sagen kann ich diese
frage bin ich finde ich ein bisschen vor
allem kommt der nächsten folge bauen wir
dann über grund weiter beide da will ich
auf tournee
nein da bin ich dabei war dabei ich habe
auch schon seit 1000 folgen dass ich mal
meine kisten sortieren werde aber nie
dazu doppelt galt ihr konkret am sonntag
online
die folge ist figuren in meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat könnt
ihr gerne eine positive bewertung da
lassen wenn ihr euch einen der ezb und
dann müssen was machen rostocks kai
sannwald schreibt es in die kommentare
an ideen und beim nächsten mal wieder